- I'll give you one guess. (laughs hard)
(chuckles)
- Ooh.
- My what?
- [Woman] Pictionary skills.
- No, I'm really bad.
- I hate games!
- Terrible.
- I'm probably not that great at it.
We shall see.
(chuckles)
- Oh, any character?
And then you're gonna guess.
That's how pictionary works.
- Okay, I know who I'm gonna draw.
- Whooa!
- I'm about to draw the easiest one,
I know how to draw.
- I don't have a technique,
so don't judge me.
- There is so much technique,
are you kidding me?
- That's supposed to be the ear.
- These are feathers, I guess.
- That's supposed to be the chin.
- I'm such a bad drawer.
- Oh, my God, that's horrible.
Hold up.
- Yasmin's gonna, kill me.
- I suck at this.
- I give up. (chuckles)
- Gorgeous!
- [Woman] Okay, so
who did you draw?
- I drew Yasmin. Nimah.
- You are gonna judge me but
you gonna tell who it is.
Bam!
See what I'm saying?
You see that is crazy!
- Sorry Kate, I made her the Joker.
- Do you like?
Do you know who that is?
Black Cindy.
- I'm the worst, I'm fired.
(chuckles)
Let me guess, Crazy Eyes?
- No! I'm kidding, I'm
kidding, I'm kidding!
- I'm like, no!?
- [Samira] What if I was that,
what if I was that bad.
- [Woman] Oh no, it's Piper!
- Piper, season 4.
- Do you want to...
Yes, it is. Here we go.
Beautiful isn't it?
True work of art.
(upbeat music)
(laughs)
- Beautiful job. (overlapping chatter)